pierre sennes nous professeurs agrégés
ovale de grave ça bonsoir professeur
merci d'être avec nous accorder un petit
peu de votre temps précieux
ces temps ci alors 6 % des français
infectées au 1er mai selon l'institut
pasteur pas suffisant selon vous
également pour éviter une seconde vague
remonter bien sûr pas suffisant mais
enfin tu des remarques vous est de dire
que c'était une estimation
certes basés sur des modèles
mathématiques qui sont certainement
performant avec des biostatisticiens de
l'institut pasteur et leurs
collaborateurs
mais pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une
estimation
ce qui est certain c'est
qu'effectivement le taux réel de
personnes infectées et sûrement tout à
fait inférieur à ce qu'on appelle le
taux nécessaire pour avoir l'immunité
troppo la heures des multi et donc pour
éviter donc est fait pour arrêter
l'épidémie
mais on pourrait avoir des idées plus
précises quand on aura des tests
sérologiques car aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas encore de test sérologique
pour pouvoir faire des enquêtes
sérologique qui nous donneront des
chiffres plus précis mais encore une
fois qu'ils sont certainement inférieur
à ce qu'on aurait pu attendre ce qu'on
aurait pu attendre mais finalement
heureusement c'est une preuve que notre
confinement a été bien respectée car la
transmission a beaucoup diminué
il ya un chiffre qui faut peut-être
ajouter c'est ce fameux air 0 qui a
diminué considérablement
considérablement car il est passé de 3 3
% environ au début de l'épidémie a
maintenant à un peu plus de 0 5%
mais pardon pardonnez moi oui continuez
votre explication
oui donc ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement la couverture donc
immunitaire est tout à fait insuffisante
pour éviter le fun le phénomène de
rebond
sauf c'est le sauf qu apporte important
et capital
si on continue à respecter les mesures
barrières et si on continue à respecter
les mesures barrières on va on va
pouvoir maintenir le r0 ou du moins ce
qu'ils n'augmentent pas beaucoup et donc
in fine et nous avons nous devrions
quand même réussir avec d'autres
facteurs à contre contrôler sans être
populiste à contrôler donc cette
épidémie s'est passé tout à fait mais
alors justement la nuancer avec d'autres
facteurs ces facteurs là est ce qu'on
les a aujourd'hui vous venez de le citer
vous même les tests sérologiques ce qui
ne sont pas une pièce absolument
maîtresse de ce succès dans la lutte du
coronavirus or on le sait qu'ils ne sont
pas prêts aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'ai
dis je malheureusement ils sont tant ils
sont en évaluation et pour est en cours
d'homologation
mais à ma connaissance ça devrait être
ces jours ci on les attend là vraiment
tous les jours et j'espère que les
industriels suivent derrière pour être
prêt à les mettre sur le marché dès
qu'ils seront homologués mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire encore
des grandes enquêtes sérologique par
faute de test effectivement alors
professeur on nous parlait d'une unité
on oublie souvent qu'il faudrait 70 %
pour jouer l'immunité collective on a du
mal à comprendre dans le contexte de
confinement ce une mission impossible on
aurait dû peut-être se prendre autrement
dans la stratégie écoutez je non je
réponds même carrément non parce qu'il
ya deux solutions
je crois que c'était répéter mais il
faut être simple et les expliquer
simplement la solution c'était de
laisser circuler le virus comme on sait
que l'immense majorité des cas sont des
cas bénins mais à quel prix c'est les
personnes âgées et on ne peut qu on ne
pouvait pas les laisser circuler le
virus pour faire une hécatombe encore
plus chez les personnes à risque et les
vieilles personnes où il ya les ehpad et
c'est donc non c'est sûrement là la
bonne
solution mais c'est clair que du coup on
n'empêche que cette immunité collective
puisse s'étendre suffisamment alors
l'étude pasteur qui estime que 0,5 pour
cent des personnes infectées en meurent
évidemment plus meurtrier que les
grippes saisonnières mais je voudrais la
ville une professeur de médecine que
vous êtes
est ce que c'est un chiffre qui est
vraiment très important comparé aux
autres causes de deux décès en france
alors là je biaiserait un petit peu pour
répondre à cette question
ce que l'on voit actuellement et le
directeur général de la santé il le
répète tous les jours c'est qu'on voit
quand même une augmentation par rapport
aux autres années de la mortalité
donc c'est clair que l'effet qu'ovide
augmente la mortalité
ça c'est certainement oui alors
l'institut pasteur également avec son
étude qui révèle une répartition très
peace riz précise par région 2 3%
notamment à paris 1,4 pour cent
nouvelles aquitaine déjà comment
l'expliquer et puis cette répartition
peut-elle être pérenne est ce qu'il ya
des régions selon vous qui vaut rester
totalement épargnés je ne crois pas je
ne dois pas il y aura sûrement quand le
confinement va être terminé
donc on pourra quand même circuler il
est évident que le virus circulera aussi
encore une fois c'est et pourrait donc
il circulera et dans les régions qui
pour l'instant sont peu atteinte mais en
respectant encore une fois c'est très
important
sinon le répèterai pas tout le temps
comme ça les mesures barrières est le
masque etc a doublé la distanciation
sociale on évitera au maximum que les
personnes à risque soit atteinte
c'est ça le but qu'il faudra atteint
mais il est clair que dans les autres
régions
effectivement le virus ne va pas
disparaître comme ça mais attendez tout
à l'heure vous
maé fait une remarque c'est que je
disais à d'autres facteurs
pour l'instant c'est un nouveau virus ce
virus à quelques mois on le connaît pas
encore parfaitement dieu sait on entend
beaucoup d'inconnues et en particulier
une inconnue c'est une éventuelle
saisonnalité c'est pas impensable
on a on on sait que pour les coronavirus
peu grave qui donne lieu à des rhumes
plus important car c'est la famille les
coronavirus est connue depuis un moment
maintenant je parle pas du sarc d'eddy
merckx bien sûr avant elle et qu on sait
que ces virus ont tendance à disparaître
pendant la belle saison et une
saisonnalité hiver d'hannover re n'a
donc on verra mais on peux pas encore le
dire ça on le souhaite et on l'espère on
l'espère fortement avec vous merci
pierre salliou professeur agrégé du val
de grâce d'avoir été avec merci de votre
de vos explications direct sur rt france